welcome to this video for around 13 of
the candidates which means
the
penultimate round this is the right word
so only two rounds to go in my coverage
and it's a bit of a late video i didn't
manage to do it right after the round it
was simply too late
they played until i don't know
after 10 o'clock in the evening and with
analysis and everything it's it's not
possible to do
so i did do this now on the day after
that
in the morning
so let's um get ahead before the round
we had chromnic leading by half a point
ahead of carlson and it's a two-person
race now
aronian is out of it after the loss in
the round before
so
kramnik leading by half a point and this
is
why i will focus on
the games of chromnic and carson
and do the two other games rather
briefly and otherwise
the video would simply be too long i
mean the
um
the games were also
really long and complicated so
let me focus on on two games um i do
grishok aronian briefly it wasn't
happening much um and basically this is
a game which is not so relevant anymore
for the standings
it's very unlikely that um
this
zomlin-born berger tie break will be
needed
which if which
would be calculated from the results of
of all players
um it's rather difficult to to explain
in case of kramnik and carlson tying
there would be various tie breaks to to
look at and if everything else is equal
then um
this zone-borne berger system would be
in effect where they calculate
the results of all the opposing players
and basically the player
gets rewarded who won the games against
the guys with more points so a win
against uh aronian or swiddler would
count more than a win against the java
for example
so this means that um
all those games would have some
relevance but it's rather unlikely now
that
this system would be needed
okay grishok aronian so basically this
is um not meaning much this game
in terms of the overall standing g3 is a
bit uncommon here against the slav
aronian takes it
but now
returns the pawn it seems that
black has no good way to to keep it
but
let's go to this yeah this is of course
a fairly standard structure in the
slav grunfeld complex
which um
this structure
which um
is um
yeah some somewhat between a very slight
advantage for white and equality
it's very difficult to make a big
progress yes right
but you're somewhat better simply
because you've got two central pawns
but it's not much yeah it's really not
much
in the game
a couple of normal moves were played
and this is uh
the idea black wants to get rid of the
queens which would
help
to
to ease some pressure
the anterior black is even threatening
to take on b3 and play bishop c2
so let's say white would play a move
like this here
then there's
this idea it's not it's not fatal this
this one is also hanging but this is one
idea
and white plays knight e3 to control the
square
and now d5 yeah so we open up the
position
and
this knight on d5 is a bit of an
annoying piece it detects e7 and
threatens knight to c7
yeah he has also weakness
basically this game um
there wasn't happening much
black is covering the weaknesses here
c5 and white has
those pawns to worry about
this probably uh cancel cancels um
on each other out there's simply not
much going on
yeah here's a funny move bishop c1
the idea being if white captures
there's knight b3 with with the really
oops
with a really big fork
and it will end will end in a draw
okay played bishop f6
knight b3 rook b5 yeah in this position
you could argue that white is probably
somewhat better he's got this
annoying bishop on f6 and he's got the
bishop pair
but it's probably not enough to
get any
meaningful advantage
a couple of moves later
the pawn here was
returned and
here we got a
repetition of moves
yeah and certainly there was a bit more
to this game than i
than i showed now but there's simply
more interesting things to cover
and it really doesn't mean much in their
overall standings
your next game is sweet agree shock
which actually was interesting
at least a bit more than the game before
but also due to
time constraints i'm not uh doing it
in so much detail
swiddler playing e4
i guess against the one shook he returns
to his old
favorite he's playing also d4 now and
and other moves but
um evancho can play anything so he
probably
felt that e4 is better suited
okay the french eventual plays any
opening
and sliddler going for the advance
he has played um various lines against
the french and the past but
the advance i think is a result of
preparation together with grishok um
they're good friends and grishok is an
expert on the advance
and they probably have analyzed it in
some detail together
so
eventual plays the nowadays
most common line with bishop d7 there's
also queen b6 but bishop d7
is maybe even somewhat more popular
bishop e2 is the normal move
some old school players still go bishop
d3 but
this is simply
simply good for black
you can you can analyze this with
various pawn sacrifices but it's
probably not enough
or maybe at best the efficient
compensation
in this position also a3 is not
considered to be so critical because of
yeah basically both f6 is good it's the
sharp move
and also c4 gains in strength compared
to
the similar position with the queen
as now the queen is not needed on b6
and black now
has um
this idea
one knight to a5 one knight to b6 and
bishop a4 and this is also the reason
why
this is better here than with the queen
on b6 as the queen on b6 blocks this
important square for the knight
so this is why a3 is not played so much
and bishop b2 is the main move yeah 97
castles
and knight g6 black has got various ways
to to play this he can also
put the knight on f5
um knight g6 however is an interesting
concept it is only a bit a bit uncommon
how eventually now continued
um right here
that's got various moves mostly plays
bishop e3 but um there are
more than one um
there's more than one possibility
g3 as played by swiddler is also
interesting
the idea is to
let's say here
is to play h4
the normal move here would be actually
let's uh can we can exchange the normal
move here would be actually bishop e7
and then there's h4
trying to harass the knight
in fact this
is a rather common way to play this
it looks a bit strange even this year
look at this
funny night
but black plays f6 and knight f7 and on
f7 the knight is actually
um yeah superbly placed
looking at the pawn on h6 looking at all
the important squares
so this is a funny idea connected with
bishop with knight to g6
but it didn't
materialize in the game as evancho
played the
much sharper move f6
it's interesting
white now took there's too much pressure
on on e5
and we captured with the queen
bishop g5 queen f7
yeah there was knight g5m there's a
somewhat annoying threat so he covered
this
so
yeah let's have a look at this position
it it's um a bit similar to
lines um in the tahrash
with knight d2
on 92 knight f6 this line
is the same pawn structure the queen is
on f7 though this is a bit uncommon
but
this of course can be a good post if you
look at
castles and the queen and the rook
have some pressure here
the knight is on g6 instead of f6
which has got
pros and cons the knight nicely controls
important squares but it's
less aggressive in a way as it
looks at lots of squares that are
covered by white pawns
it's an interesting uh position and
black shouldn't be um in big danger
unless it happens what swiddler played
he played the most critical line now
knight b5
bishop returns
where else it needed to cover c7 and now
knight e5 this is by far the the
critical way to play it and they were
also on their own now look at the times
it's not like
this was um any preparation
however if you look at evan shook
one hour
he already spent one hour and four
behind on the clock
this is of course tricky in this
position it's really complicated
um yeah well what is this the support
blunder i know it isn't there's an idea
black took it
bishop c5 bishop e5 is actually a
similar
bishop c5 this is the idea before black
gets to castle
white um
man just to put a bishop here
and it's uh very difficult now for for
black to to get the king into safety
the basic idea also is at one point to
play knight to d6
and get this great bishop on d6 if black
for example let's say a very simple way
to play
if you played something like this
somewhat
passively this is uh simply
um awful for black to play
it's just normal moves here
are good enough
the king never will get any any kind of
safety
the rook is well placed on the c file so
if black would remove the knight there's
always
this kind of stuff
and you all you also cannot cast along
in this position this is simply simply
not on
look at this for example this is why the
rook is on c1
so this is the general idea ivancio
played knight c4 he actually played this
um part of the game
really well
he only stumbled uh stumbled later
um yeah knight c4 this attacks this to
b5 knight
and what is white supposed to do in fact
when i watched the game
i thought that simply bishop takes c4
should be good
but it's not clear at all this looks
this looks really dangerous
queen here and now b6
yeah the question is how do you continue
now if you put the bishop somewhere here
i mean let's say here
then black has got
a queen move maybe here
and you manage to unravel or queen e7
it's also probably okay
so
it stays on this diagonal and here
black actually can play long castles
it looks it looks a bit shaky but it
seems to be seems to be possible there's
not much uh threatened i mean something
like this let's say
you you can even play play this move
it's it's it's not it's not losing
and like has got ways to
maybe at some point even get on the
diagonal
it's uh probably even better for black
this wasn't helping switzerland played
much better he played b3
and um yeah now what is black supposed
to do he must play this move now b6
um
he cannot play bishop takes b5
after this capture it's it's too shaky
for black you simply get your position
now opened up
and
you you will not be able to hold this
let's for for example
bishop c6 bishop h5 very important move
after which black must play g6 otherwise
the queen is gone of course
and something like this is um is
impossible for black to play
just look at this crossfire of bishops
black has simply no way to defend
against screen takes d5
something like this
yeah there's a multitude of moves
this is winning on
all this even attacking the rook
yeah it's it's not possible
evancho played the only move b6
and the only thing is look at the clock
times
he's
getting dangerously
low now a5
these are all only moves it's not
much else that black can play
and now we took it this is a slightly
different position than before
if white now instead of this
takes on c4
this is um
this is um playable it seems
for example bishop h5 g6
bishop takes h8
and bishop takes f1
while being a very um
murky position
this uh
did i confuse something here
let's uh let's look i have my node cm
my analysis
b takes c4
oh i simply i simply looked at the wrong
line here yeah black can take here
bishop h5 g6
and this is not completely clear after
taking on h8 black of course takes here
and
it's not it's not not so easy to assess
this
black's got two pawns for the exchange
and a very strong bishop on c4 and this
somehow um
ties the position together in a way
rookie one
and bishop d6
yeah
this is uh maybe maybe okay i mean black
probably even can play king d7 at some
point and b5
it's not clear
it's a
similar to the game actually
yeah this is this is um somewhat similar
so
if white would take on c4 for example we
would get
exactly the same position
this is why swiddler played the move
rookie one
and
this really sets difficult problems the
threat is queen takes d5 of course
and
here in this position ivan shook
made this um
yeah with not much time on the clock um
played to play the wrong move it's
simply very very difficult of course
um here the computer actually
gives a really amazing line
starting with knight d6
the idea is
queen d5
and now the cool move king d7
i'm not sure
how a human is supposed to find such
stuff but it's very interesting now
queen takes
and bishop c6 this is the big idea
you want the queen f3 counter play
queen b8 and queen f3
and in fact this position is a draw
really amazing this
of course is a big threat
if you go here there's check
this happening and we just have a
repetition
and what can white do we can give a
check but then you have got this neat
move and might be seven
and well we can give another check and
i'll go here
and at the end of all this
white has no way to prefer prevent the
maid he needs to
well he needs to go here to to set up
this
repetition of moves
but um he has no way way to win the game
actually the queen is offside and uh
this is strong
yeah this uh probably would have been
the
fair result of the game
they both played really well i think
if we look at it with the computer it
doesn't find much improvements but he
didn't see this move or did some um
miscalculation what he played is queen
to f5
which isn't uh so terrible probably i
mean it's it's leading to an advantage
for white but
the main thing also was that he was down
to eight minutes now
look at this
white is somewhat better because of
his um
safer king position black never will get
a really good king position and this
bishop is returning to e5
here
here bishop a7 would have been an
improvement with the idea b5
to get some play against f2 and this
actually isn't so clear
it's uh it's still playable for for
black white is better but um it's it's
something to uh to play
here
this is the relatively best continuation
something like this
and the game continues it is it is much
better for white but you can you can
continue to fight
after this
it's too much because you also have big
problems with the king
and yeah well you're down to four
minutes so
um
around here it was uh very obvious that
evan shop will have problems again
to uh to make the time control
and
now it was down to 40 seconds
this is another exchange
lost but um it didn't really matter
check
and here on ivan shook overstepped the
time limit
yeah
a good game by swiddler i think he
really is playing a good tournament i
mean everybody is um focusing mostly
with good cause
um on the first place race which is very
very exciting but um
everybody is um
there are other players playing in the
tournament and swindler is doing a good
job i mean it's not
he's uh magnus last round opponent and
uh it's uh
it's not like uh swindler is in in bad
shape i mean he played
um he lost against kromnic
and against uh carlson but uh he he won
three games
and uh quite convincing fashion even so
he's uh he's in in good form
i'd also like to address briefly a
subject that sometimes comes up in in in
in some
chats or in in
forums or whatever
that people blame you one shook for
somehow um
i don't know um distorting the
the
standings because he's uh
well playing like a genius against
carlson and playing like a [ __ ] against
the others this is simply not true i
mean this is
people who um actually write this only
proof that they have no idea about this
game
the thing is evancho is an erratic
player has been an erectic player all
his life
even if 20 years ago he's doing it all
the time he's playing like
great the one day and like uh
really very strangely
on
on the day after that it's nothing
special that is happening in this
tournament it's simply his normal way of
of proceeding
and the thing is
people sometimes they claim hey you
played great against magnus well i don't
think so i mean what he did is he just
mopped up this position where carson
basically self-destructed
it didn't take a
2750 player like one shot to win this
game really i don't think so
um the way mangas played this game he
could have lost against any
2500 player he he simply
lost the game he evancho didn't so much
win it and this was also what he wanted
said in the press conference the only
thing that he didn't do is overstep the
time
but the thing is
evancho lost some time this game as well
but he was also totally busted on the
board and he was had really difficult
problems which didn't happen in the
carlton game carden didn't set him any
big problems he just needed to make the
normal moves and and that's it
um
so um i really don't understand some of
those discussions
um all right so this was um the swiddler
eventual game and now
let's go to the
to the main course so the same
um
i am by the way ivan shook is playing in
the last round against kromnic so um
it's very interesting to see uh how we
will play but uh i think evan shook is
not the kind of player you want to have
in the last round where you probably
need to win the game you never know what
happens he might help you but you might
also play the game of his life it can
happen all the time
okay so now um
kramnik against girlfriend
and uh well it's um
it's clear
that um
kromnic wanted to press in this game
trying to win but
obviously not losing
this is the
the difficult thing you know you're in a
tight race and you want to keep your
winning options open but you don't want
to risk too much
and in fact he came really close um
to win in this game let's see what
happens
again g3 it's it's curious he obviously
has prepared the
fianchetto line against the grunfeld and
king's indian setups
kromnik
has been very successful with for
example the bionet attack
against um
the king's indian but here he plays g3
he played knight c3 against swiddler
and managed to get in some some good
preparation but here g3 bishop
c6 yeah
this is a very solid line with d5
yeah here the most common way to play is
actually to take on d5
or to to cover the pawn in some way so
like let's say here knight f3
bishop g7 and then cover the pawn like
like this
or like
b3
and
the most common mover ever is taking and
this is a very solid uh
very solid position
which very often um is drawn actually
it's a bit similar to the to the
exchange slav but both sides have fear
and shadowed
however in this position amazingly
kromnic played the move e3
and
yeah this is really um amazing about
chess i have
close to 800 games in my database
with the position here before e3
and this is has never been played
it's a it's a it's a genuine novelty and
at least in top level chess
i mean it's possible that um
it was played in some local tournament
or something but it's uh it's a genuine
novelty on move five in uh
in top level chess it's really
interesting
um yeah and
the thing is it it's also a bit of a
weird move um
it would struck me off very
very strange actually because the
combination of g3 and e3
um is is often um
is often
a bit questionable if black can take the
pawn on c4 which is what galvan did as
you don't have a natural way to to to to
uh to regain the pawn
it's similar to the catalan where
um
this pawn cannot be recap captured by
the bishop because it is on g2
however it seems to be okay for white i
mean kramnik gets the pawn back fast
enough
it still would have been interesting
what um
what white would have played
if uh if like simply would have
completed development let's say bishop
g7
i guess
something like this and uh
then it's uh it's not clear what right
this is going to do next when you play
this move
or whatever it's it's not clear at all
well girlfriend decided to take it after
a long thing he obviously was surprised
it's clear i mean this is a novelty on
mu5 and also it's not a move that
strikes you of being too logical
but okay
crumb nick
certainly succeeded in gaining time on
the clock with this innovation
and the next couple of moves
we played somewhat quicker
and knight a3 this is the idea getting
the pawn back
and then you have a really typical
position where white has this extra pawn
in the center this is not too
different um to the aronian
game of the same round with black
against squishook
this extra center pawn white has got a
fear shadowed bishop
look here
so this this position should be
very slightly better for white he's got
a good open
diagonal and he's got
after knight b6
this move knight a5 which is a motif
that is that's worth remembering
the knight is very often
nicely placed on a5
if
if you get this paw information
it simply
attacks
the queen side and black has a hard time
first with developing the bishop
and then with getting rid of this piece
which always attacks b7 if you move the
b pawn there's always c6 to take
so what i'm talking about is let's just
for argument's sake play this this you
can never play or very
only after preparation play a move like
v6 as this pawn is always hanging
and this means that this knight is
putting very annoying pressure on the
queen side
95 was just a move to illustrate this
it's a it's a stupid move
yeah girlfriend played queen c7 which is
preparing e5 and makes much sense this
is the drawback of
the drawback of white's position it
didn't really um
control e5
yeah b4 and e5
very logical play
and now um white could have also played
a move like
let's say bishop b2 here
but he was probably a bit worried about
black advancing
and getting the d5 square
this is why he um he took on e5 to make
sure that the position opens up queen
takes
and knight d4
yeah how to assess this position it's
not easy to play as black this is this
is clear
especially with more than 40 minutes
clock disadvantage and this is mostly
because
there's pressure on those pawns
it's not easy for black to to find
squares for pieces the bishop on c8 for
example is not easy to develop
and white has got some nice
pieces
defender played this really well i think
knight e4
rookie 8
yeah he he went back now
get out of
possible trouble and preventing b5
rook t1
and h5 this is a good move trying to
play h4
which is it's not strictly an attacking
move the idea is
if you manage to exchange the h pawns
then
white can never play f3 as then g3 is
hanging
f3 e4 could be a good idea for white
under the right circumstances but it's
much um
harder to do if black has exchanged on
g3 to illustrate i just make a couple of
moves that don't make much sense here
too
just to to show it
but you can more easily see what i'm
talking about if white would
go with um
i don't know
let's play some move with f3 then
there's simply this pawn hanging and
this is the difference if you have
exchanged the h pawns
this is uh
a good idea to remember the same applies
of course if white plays h4 which would
be really a bad move it just weakens the
the king side you will never be able to
play a 3 now due to the pawn on g3
krumlin played rook d3 which is much
stronger
this has
more than one idea it protects the pawn
at the knight
and allows this pawn advance
at the later stage it also covers e3
which is a sensitive spot in white's
position
knight d5
and rook t1 this is all very
very well played i think
chromnic had about 20 minutes more on
the clock this is important
yeah what about taking on before now
it's a
it's not really good because of
this tactical move
it's a it's a big pin and if black
takes the queen
there's 97 with check this is the
problem
and white will win
also e4 is hanging and after that the
rook so
many pieces hanging black couldn't take
he played bishop to g4 which is a good
move again
he thought he's playing this uh really
well i think
bishop g4 so what about f3 yeah this is
um
the most obvious move but it's bad
really
black can
take on g3
it's not the only move but
this is the main reason why um
while it was it wasn't played have a
look at this
applying
a really
really nasty fork here between moves
something like this if you look at this
black's got two pawns and rook
for two minor pieces
and white doesn't have good coordination
in this position even if he takes
um
yeah black goes to f5
not much regard for his pawn structure
but he wants to have
the active pieces you cannot afford to
go all the way back to 2c8
let's say takes
and black then will
centralize and it's clear that black has
some advantage it's not quite quite
clear how much it is but
this is certainly nothing that white can
allow
also always remember that kromnic needed
to play in a way
that you don't risk too much a loss at
this point is simply fatal
let's say he would lose the game
and carson would win
then it's it's basically over if he's
half a point behind carlson then carlsen
needs a draw with white in the last
round so he cannot lose the game as
white it's simply not on
cannot risk too much
um okay so what is white supposed to
play he played rook c1 now
in fact there also was an alternative
and this is
this move
it's a it's probably not so great but
it's something you need to calculate
the idea is of course that the knight on
d5 is hanging
it leads to great complications queen e6
rook takes and now knight c3 and this is
a position you
should look at for
for quite a moment because
it's uh
it's really amazing how much
pieces are hanging yeah d5 d1 even
double by the knight and the bishop
there's this hanging and there's also
the knight on c6 hanging
so uh white has
sacrificed
yeah a piece first on c6 but got the
piece back on d5 so his two pawns up but
there's everything hanging in this
position and it seems that the tactics
work out
nicely for black
there are some ways to um
to even get in trouble that's right and
this is i think why kramnik avoided this
always keep in mind he can he should try
to win but he never ever can afford a
loss in this game
one one line which is possible knight d4
retreating
and attacking the queen
this could lead to a very forcing
sequence let's have a look
gaining a tempo
this is not 100 force but it's close
this kind of position you can easily
lose is white really easily
you have two pawns for the exchange
but if black manages to to enter on c2
for example
you need to be cautious here
just for example
this would be hugely different if this
bishop would be on c5 for example then
white is playing for win but
here
this a3 a2 configuration is really
unlucky
like we'll will win the pawn
and
something like this
this is the position that kramnik of
course must avoid at all costs here only
black can win it's not clear if he if he
can manage but
you will never win as white and you get
tortured
and as mentioned the loss is fatal
just one line and he avoided all this
and played rook c1 a very good decision
i think
after this after rook c1 you can simply
continue the game and and press
and you don't risk
risk losing
yeah now a very interesting and i think
good
approach by um
by by girlfriend
he
took on d4 very concrete
and uh and good play
the idea is that of course their white
needs to be captured with the rook
and now he went knight g5 and this uh
makes some sense
you give up the dark squared bishop
now to get big influence on the light
squares
and uh maybe even on a good day you get
a mating attack
so a very very good way to to play
now kromnic went queen d3
and
here
gerfand
i think
made a slight mistake here he could have
gotten a relatively
easy to play and good position with the
move
on
bishop f3
the idea is that of course white cannot
take this is very easy
losing the exchange
and you um
yeah you simply
put the bishop in the in the heart of
white's camp and trying to exchange it
and you fight for
for for the light squares if white plays
a move like b5 which looks very good at
first attacking the queen you play queen
e6 and this now gets very tricky
very tricky for white how do you um
cover the light squares
it's uh it's really difficult now let's
say you go queen f1 to to cover all this
then there's
this shot
check
and it's it's a big problem
this is all hanging
especially the knight the bishop is
saying
yeah in fact after queen e6 white is in
big trouble and will probably lose the
game
it's um
very hard to to even
think about
drawing here b5 is a big mistake
um
probably white must must play or can
play move like e4 for example
then
white um
a black can exchange the bishop
and has a very nice pressure here on e4
let's say f3
h4 just a sample line and i think a line
that should be very much okay for black
he
has good pieces he can always also drop
the knight back to e6 play rook d8
and i think this should be quite okay
for black
in the game he got into some trouble he
played knight f3 it looks good yeah but
it has got a concrete problem
now after b5 how do you protect the
queen side
in fact um
there's no way to do it
played queen e6
knight 97 there was a pawn gone anyway
of course black has got
some um
compensation in the form that this
bishop is very strong
and
you have counterplay on the light
squares
this is what happened
threatening mate
queen here
takes takes
rook 6
knight b5 this is probably what
girlfriend
had in mind when he went for for all
this and
black has got as mentioned some
compensation
one point is that
you also always have this this idea
counter play against the a pawn and
white's king is of course
stuck um yeah at the back rank
yeah girlfriend played this
rook b8 move in fact if you look at this
with um with the engine it points out
that
rook b6 is supposed to be stronger
yeah maybe it is but
it's difficult for a human girlfriend
was down to six minutes
also due to this opening surprise which
costs lots of time
and um
here
this is the idea
to now go to asics
this kind of continuation
this is what the computer gives
it's probably better than the game i am
i think i agree the idea is that the
pressure on
a2 is very
very annoying and it's difficult for
white to
to untangle this
in the game as mentioned he played rook
b8
and knight d6 this is a difference the
rook doesn't
doesn't work here on a6
and f6 here
if you look at this it seems that white
should have something the computer
gives all kinds of lines leading to a
very big advantage
but it's in fact not 100 percent clear
if
if some of them are really going to uh
to lead to a win
for example
rook d2c4 is a computer line that
kramnik didn't play
and the computer says okay white is
winning with this but if you look at
this a little bit deeper you you will
see that it's not so clear-cut even 1.5
by the computer doesn't really mean it
it's winning in some cases
look at this check
it looks very good yeah but
still
are you sure that white is going to win
this actually i am not sure
this can easily end in a draw black's
got counter play with
rook here the king is insecure look at
the white squares here
bishop f3 rook d1 is checkmate
along these lines
the computer is from 1.5 but it's not
clear that this is winning
it's made in its main line is fy5 and
how can white be on 1.5 here i simply
don't see it it's just the a pawn and if
you exchange rook you probably draw the
game
it's even this is not 100 percent clear
yeah kramnik played rook f4 which is
also very understandable he wanted to
get rid
of this bishop which is always
irritating white
and yeah girlfriend dropped back
rook c2
and rookie for a knight e4 geffron
played this uh this part of the game i
think excellent in in terms of
move quality per per time it's it's
great how he defended this position
um here there were also was rook d8 also
interesting move
which is probably also um
okay for black
he played this
knight knight to e4
and allowed
knight takes f7
which at first looks uh looks bad but he
had an idea of course rook a6 this was
the counter play idea
attacking the bishop
and attacking the knight so
both
pieces
are under attack
and yeah kramnik didn't have much choice
needed to drop the bishop back
and here in this position i think
girlfriend commits the only um
real mistake that the teammate made in
the game
and um
this actually offered kromnic some
chances to win the game
what uh what would have drawn but this
is a very very theoretical thing to say
because he's got three minutes and this
is a very computer-ish line
move that would have been drawn
instantly
instantly
but not easily it's rook c1
um there will be one rupee one sorry
um the idea is um
on rook c7 which looks super dangerous
threatening knight h6 and rook f8 mate
that on this move you play g5
and this is the the very difficult move
to see
as the a6 rook
suddenly
covers the h6 square
knight g5
the next move you need to have an answer
to
the point is that this
is winning for white
very hard to see
but
but
it's a
this move
that saves the game now attacking c1
it
blocks the connection here
and white now must play rook take c6
there is not not much else
black can check
win a pawn
in the
on the go and he will get
check
this as well
this kind of position and here of course
black can never lose he can simply
play this and
sort of
pursue writes rook eternally with the
draw
white can never exchange of course he
will lose the a pawn and the game
so rook b1 was
the way to to draw the game but it's i
mean who's supposed to see this with few
minutes
it's not possible simply
you can you can play the right move but
it's more than a
matter of luck
and also there are other things to
consider here white for example also has
the move f3
which is answered by rook takes a2
also something you need to
see beforehand
the point being that rook c8 check
king g7 f takes e4
bishop f7
rook c7
is answered by king g8
and this is a draw
yeah white can lose of course so yeah
you can
check me made yourself
or this one
which after this
continuation leads to a drawn rook end
game
yeah rook b1 but uh okay who is supposed
to see that
girlfriend played rookie 8
which
protects the knight and attacks this
knight so it forces white's hand in a
way
rook c7
and rook a2 this was the idm
check
and in this position
maybe there's the
the point where
kromnik
could have gotten a very big advantage
maybe but
the thing is that even this isn't 100
clear
the move to to go was g form
in this position
it's not a very intuitive move
the idea is to to take on h5 and then
play rook f5
so um
if black plays
i don't know a move like a5 here using
the pawn
then there's the capture
and rook f5 and this is actually
relatively easy witness
after the capture on h5 there's simply
tons of discoveries and black's king is
in a terrible crossfire it's also two
two pawns down
so this is not possible black probably
needs to take it
oh
here
needs to take it
and then young knight recaptures
the the the positive point about all
this is that the white knight manages to
escape
from uh from its square on h6
and this is here very difficult to to
assess
there are some lines that the computer
assesses as winning
but i'm not sure if it is really winning
it's always those opposite coded bishops
that can
can save black by exchanging rooks
for example without any rooks this
position is probably just a draw
with not much
going on act really
one line that the computer gives for
example is bishop g8 i'm not even sure
what this move is doing
but just to show it or the computer gets
something like this as
leading to a big big edge for for white
but i'm not so sure how exactly uh do
you win now it's uh
it's always a bit a bit tricky with with
possible counter play
the
bishop if it's at one point gets back to
the diagonal
something like this i'm not sure i mean
this is obviously
um
very good for white but if it's winning
it's it's a completely
different story but this is uh the
chance probably that that kromnic had um
after
what he played
here again he could have repeated once
and played g4 but
he uh
set his he put his hopes on this f3 move
and this actually uh doesn't seem to to
be enough
therefore took now with very little time
on the clock
and rook d8 this is what he had prepared
very nice threatening checkmate and now
black's counter play i think works
perfectly to a draw
i think it was a really well played game
i mean the level of play in this game
was was really really high considering
that they have played 13 rounds and not
with any kind of 10 move draws or
something very rarely
um they played played non
yeah non-eventful draws it was really a
big big fight in most of the games and
uh really look at the the quality of
this game they're very little very
little mistakes girlfriend defended uh
defended uh
very well i think
so rook d8
with this um counter attack
and um
check
comic game gave checks first here to
make mu 40
here in fact
he had a funny possibility bishop h3
a3
which the computer at first likes a lot
but it doesn't seem to to lead too much
i give a possible variation rook takes
of course you must take otherwise it's
made
and what it is doing it it prevents the
checkmate so
you can actually take him and now rook
p2 this is black's counter play of
course
threatening
the mate
the idea of all this is the following
which defense against the maid
and
what what is the possible consequence
check
check it's this uh this rook and game
coming up
just a possible line
and here black can simply jettison the
pawn
and this is just a draw
it's quite funny um what what some
engines think about this position
it's it's up it's just a draw and very
obvious for for humanness it doesn't
make any difference if white has got one
or two pawns
it's not a big difference um
and
houdini is like plus 1.5 if you don't
give it to table basis table base
immediately shows a draw
um but if you give it to
to a somewhat weaker engine like
stockfish it gives like plus four
which is just uh just funny because it's
really a relatively easy draw
okay this is not a completely forced
line but it shows that black's got very
good drawing chances
okay well krom nick gave those check
checks as mentioned
but
he of course didn't want to draw he
tried everything to to win the game
simply because he also observed that
um
that magnus was
i can tell that much pressing for for
win not with with the
big prospects but he was pressing for a
win and kromnik certainly wanted to
to um yeah try the utmost in in this
game to
to to win it
so king you want to get rid of the maid
threat and here
in this position girlfriend
almost invents rested 20 minutes you he
got this one hour extra it's
a bit difficult to fathom here he got he
had
about two minutes left
before time control
and the clock springs to 43 so he spent
almost 20 minutes on this move
um in fact knight c3 also was drawing
but this is um
a good way good way to do it
you can still easily
make mistakes let's say knight f2
with the mate threat
this unfortunately
runs into something like this
check
check
and this knight
is on a very set set post on f2 it can
it can never go anywhere only to h3
which is a bit sad
this was bad yeah but knight c5 is
simply simply okay
with this idea
check
give checks
check
check
and now try it tried this check knight
d3 check
and king to the side yeah is threatening
the maid
so black must go here
check
check
check
check yeah here girlfriend took took a
while to really work it out to to the
draw
he calculated until the end i think
when he invested a couple of minutes
now there's this thread
white cannot go here because of rook d1
made this is the counter play
e4 so he calculated up to this point i
think and now he saw that um he's got
one way to to draw this and this is
simply pushing the a pawn
why try to not take it but it's
unavoidable at some point and then rook
d2
the idea was simply to get the rooks of
the seventh rank so that there's no made
threat and now you threaten this
perpetual on the second rank and it's uh
it's just dead now
um
what's the degree drawn here
yeah rook a7 and rook g2 and the draw
white has no way to play for wins yeah
if you look at this for example
giving giving checks
you can
easily lose here how do you how do you
even avoid that you lose
the pawnee if you if you go back for
example
check
check
check
check
check
something like this you can easily lose
the game
and by this you you lose all chances in
the tournament
so white needs to
to draw now rook a7
with the counter threat of mate
forces the draw rook g2 and draw agreed
so um a really good game
what can you say only
if you look at this with the engine it
only points out really minor mistakes
and
a really great level of play after
that long um of a tournament and uh
let's not forget that um
that
it's also a matter of agent and stamina
and those are not
those two are not young boys anymore
okay so a good a good game really by by
both players but it's just
just a draw
and this means uh
that um
carlton's game is really essential now
um if he if he draws just to to make out
some to to line up some scenarios if he
draws the game then uh krom nick goes
into the final round with half a point
advantage and it's sort of still open
the the race but
um
still kramnik with half a point ahead
holds the advantage but if carson wins
the game then he would
be on equal points with kromnic and he
would have the better tiebreak because
he has this extra
win because he lost one game he and won
one game
compared to krumnik who played draws and
and wins so there's this crazy tie break
with
uh more wins means your head result what
also
this implies is that if you have lost
games then you're in your head okay
let's go to to magnus game
the job of against carlson
a job of went um one d4
and
so now it's curious what opening
is magnus going to play he certainly
needs to
sort of
keep the ball in the game yeah just
get the game going and trying to keep
winning chances without risking too much
because
while he's half a point behind kromnic
and there's even the scenario let's see
he loses the game kramnik wins or draws
then it's over so he can never ever lose
the game as black he needs to
try to
play in a way that it continues and he
maybe has got something
but
not risking too much so
what is he going to play yeah the nimzo
it's
the opening for all occasions so to say
you can play it
if you um
yeah
for for
if you play for win you can play it you
can play it to stay solid it's it's so
flexible
um and i think a really good choice it
wouldn't have helped to
to play anything crazy here like and say
binoni or something
just uh play a complex game and see what
see what happens
yeah queen c2 the classical line
that uh always um that has always been
one of white's what's main moves
and rajabov had played this already
before again squisho could play d5
cards never ever plays d6
which is quite typical of his um
opening approach
he very often doesn't mind to
to play sidelines and just get a
playable position not trying to
get in anything fancy
um one move one certain advantage of
this move is that um
pieces stay on the board and it remains
in a way complex maybe in a way complex
that black is even slightly worse
but you maintain a complicated position
or a position which
involves some fight
just for example if you go d5 that is
what what grishook played
there's the line that
was played in this game and black
doesn't really have much
to avoid this this is very difficult to
play for witness as black if white
doesn't want to risk anything here
it's it's very tough to play for witness
black
with g6 you keep the pieces on the board
and
knight f3 white can also play bishop g5
for example
after which black has various ideas he
can play for instance this
has been played recently
one idea being that sometimes you even
not exchange instantly on c3 but play
bishop a5 if it is attacked
interesting line
but rajabov decided to just develop
normally
97. here black also has the possibility
to play knight c6 which transpose into
the zurich variation this will be the
one of the lines that i will feature in
my in my upcoming book
but knight d7 of course is a viable
alternative
it's a bit more flexible on the square
and you can also use the c pawn now
we will see
g3 castles
all this looks very normal c6 is a good
move it's directed against the bishop
and it also prevents knight d5 ideas in
some positions knight g5 can be annoying
um yeah here white has got
quite quite some options he went first
rook d1
rookie 8
and now um he exchanged on e5
this is certainly not not bad i mean
it's not so ambitious but
it's not not a bad move
an interesting way to play in this
position is the move e3
keeping
this pawn center intact
he maybe didn't didn't want that because
at some point black black plays maybe e4
i don't know
in this concrete position it's probably
uh
i don't know maybe maybe even here
something like this
that seems playable for black
it's interesting though e3 keeps uh
pressure
or keeps the tension pressure is the
wrong word he took only five it's not a
bad move it's just uh simplifying a bit
and now a3
um
yeah here black also could have kept the
bishop drop it all the way back
or to c7 or not here c7
but um
carson simply recaptured or captured on
c3
and played queen e7 he just played it in
a simple but but very
healthy fashion
um here it's quite funny i think
that uh
houdini my engine
and every top place engine also
recommends the funny move knight h4
which i frankly speaking don't
understand at all i don't know what this
knight is doing on h1
black just goes here
and maybe at some point knight g6 and
you really ask to say what the heck are
you doing on h4
well i don't understand the move to be
honest
um yeah he went b4
and this is a move that is actually
debatable it looks very normal but
it entails a
certain risk and this means
here the c4 pawn the c4 pawn is a bit
weak now
you could have also played just a b3
maintaining this uh
this structure um
and not not weakening c4
it leads to an unclear position black
can
for instance play e4
let's say here
and now um let's say here
this is interesting it's not not clear
how to assess this position maybe here
controlling this square and then
bishop somewhere
it's probably
between uh slight advantage for white
and equal
black has got some chances but white has
got two bishops
it's got a good square here i don't know
white is probably a slightly better
he went before though
knight b6 immediately eyeing this
weakness
and here i think white should have
played a4
to fight for an advantage
is playing a5
after e4
knight somewhere i don't know where
here
maybe
this is a very complicated position with
with still chances for why to to play
for for an edge
however he played bishop e3 and i'm not
sure what this move is doing
i think it simply concedes any hopes for
an advantage but i don't know
khan played knight g4 normal move
attacking the knight at the bishop sorry
attacking the bishop
and um
white cannot play bishop c5
because of this
embarrassing reply
this actually wins for black outright
it's not even slightly better or
something it wins
it takes here
knight c3 and now
there's too much hanging
e7 is not really hanging because of uh
made on d8 but
just have a brief look at this line
and white uh gets
ah
it's simply a terrible position
look at the knights here
really ugly so white is much worse
probably losing yeah knight d2 this was
necessary to cover c4
and now carlson read f5
yeah and you see that knight g4 and f5
really helped like a lot
the pawn on f5 prevents any knight e4
ideas
like knight e4 to d6
and simply gain space
rajab of played h3 this wasn't strictly
necessary
but
still good i think
to to clarify the situation
took
and e4 this is a strong move before
so
it's accepting
that long term maybe you have a bad
bishop it's looking at the at your own
pawns
at those pawns but it guarantees that
white's bishop is out of the out of the
game it's simply blocked and it gives
black a space space advantage this is
very important
at this stage i think black has a very
good equality
and even chances to to play for more
note that
rajabov was
about 20 minutes behind on the clock
this is very important in this game
the clock management
played rook c1
bishop 6
queen c3
and now um cars went
rook d8 yeah rook
d8 bishop f1 here in this position
there's actually an interesting
recommendation by the computer and this
is bishop f7 this wasn't played
but it seems very strong really i'm not
sure why carson rejected this
i think he must have considered the move
it has got two ideas it's got the e3
idea
shattering white structure
and also bishop h5 which can be a good
idea attacking this point the thing is
e3 is such a big threat here
white maybe needs to play e3 himself and
this is so ugly
look at this
and black has an excellent position
i'm really curious why he didn't play
that it looks really strong
okay i understand he played c5
which is a very good long-term move it
basically means that
you
try to fix this pawn on a light square
and it sort of guarantees that in the
long run black will always have chances
to to do something so this alternative
was strong i think
c5 yeah
now we're job of
surprised
me and lots of spectators by taking
he
basically figured i think that
okay i'm
worsening my pawn structure
but i managed to exchange some
some pieces and probably will draw the
existing structure
let's see what happens knight a4 of
course
queen here knight c5
knight b3 this was certainly his
his plan
and
thousand plate
this
and this is probably the strongest way
to go about it
not exchange too much if black
takes here
this looks very nice i mean you you
attack
this weakness but white will
protect
and how do how do you make progress it's
it's very difficult
for black to get anything substantial in
this position
knight six was better keeping a bit more
pieces on the board
and here a job offer exchanged queen c
didn't need to necessarily but
i think what he was after is
was this position
with the active rook and you've got the
knight coming here
he assessed that he would be able to to
draw this
um
in fact this is probably um true white
should draw but
it's clear that cars will play
this until
yeah hell freeze is over
and in fact this is what happened this
is one of the longest games i ever
covered in in a video
rook d8 so um here i was quite surprised
to see that
carson played a knight to c5
i was really expecting rookie 8
exchanging the rooks
oh
white can probably retreat yeah but uh
to to make sure that the rook is
expelled from um
from from black's camp
i think it's it's hard to do without uh
without the rook exchange
well he played a knight c5
and here in in retrospect i was really
i'm really curious why java didn't
exchange
i understand that the knight has got a
good square on g4
but taking on c5 looks really drawish in
my my book
just have a look at this
um of course black has got
got play still
g5
king to e5 and so on it's it's still
a bit of something for black black is
the only
only one to to do to do something in the
in the position but
it still feels relatively
yeah like white should draw relatively
easily
but um he didn't do it
played um
knight here
which is not bad i mean it's a good
position of the night
you can do it
he was uh low on time if you see this
got a couple of
more moves here in time trouble
h6 i think actually h6 is a slight
mistake but
it's uh
it's not not punished
i think
if you look at this now
a couple of moves later
here rook c7 the idea is of course white
cannot capture this trap the rook
but white has got this possibility now
and i think
this should should help him
damaging the pawn structure on the king
side
black has no no big choice here you can
not prevent that white takes you cannot
go here of course it's just loses even
and you probably need to play something
like this
and continue from there
and i really don't see how black um is
going to win this position
now with those two weaknesses that he
needs to to take care of
you simply don't exchange the rooks and
stay on the eighth rank
it looks i think okay
but never forget he's down to one minute
something and it's hard to
make those decisions with little time
he wanted to make the time control first
and now
magnus
simply prevents this idea
good
a good decision i think check
yeah this was the last move
to make a before time control
king 5
and frankly speaking the next couple of
moves that's not happening much
check
check
the interesting moment comes now
look at this position
why to move
why not just play okay well the next
move is okay but look at the clock
43 minutes
spent 15 minutes on rook b8
carlton played rook b7
check and after another 10 minutes or
something he's changed the rooks
i simply didn't understand why do that i
mean
it's still a draw
but
why not keep the rooks on how does black
improve his position i simply don't see
it
black can shuffle all day long his
pieces but you won't
make any big progress he you just detect
this pawn
how does this black improve here i have
no idea
i have no idea um
well it still should draw but
i didn't understand why rajabov kept
changing the position and
not simply simply kept it in a way
okay it's
still not
a dramatic thing to to
it's nothing to to criticize too too
harshly
yeah
it's a bit of shuffling
and this is actually
um
a very important thing to to learn it it
took me took me a really long while
of playing chess to understand that
sometimes it's a good policy to to do
nothing
and this is what black is doing he's
doing not much
sort of shuffling around
and
still
inducing little ideas here like king d6
knight d7 e5 king c5 attacking this and
so on but you just need to
prolong the game and make sure that the
clock is going down to increase the
pressure
this is what carson does perfectly in
the game he simply
continues and sets those little little
problems like this how do you defend
this and so on
and um
this led to
further decline on
rajabov's clock
so we are past move 60 now and it's
important to see carson got 30 39
minutes left
and rajab is down to 16 and now we are
in this sudden death period where it's
uh
16 minutes for the rest of the game but
with 30 seconds increment so it's not a
matter of playing on time or anything
it's simply that the clock is going down
and therefore the the pressure is
increased
but rajabov is not in danger of losing
on time really
as he's get getting this 30 seconds
check
yeah and here he made a really
surprising move
and um
i'm not not sure why really he played a4
which looks at first sight
really terrible
white plays a pawn on the light squares
it looks like a beginner's move to be
honest
but of course it's not
something that he um
yeah he was aware of the dangers of
course he's not a it's not a bad player
the thing is
he's got concrete ideas
with this move and
they are they are working this is the
fun thing but it uh it sets um
it demands very precise play by white in
the next couple of moves
while it's not clear what uh what
actually is happening if white is doing
nothing
just stay in the position
what uh what what's happening here now
this is actually bad
sorry
it was a bad example
um oops check
did to go back to the position sorry
you played a4 you can you can stay
instead of playing a4
but you need to do it properly let's say
here
and um
what is black doing now
how do you improve
after this move you go here it's not on
king here can't get hit by the check
this is actually a bit similar to the
game but you don't have the pawn on a4
yeah to cut it short it wasn't necessary
to play like this his idea is
is tactical he wants to play c5
and exchange pawns
but let's see what happens he's down to
five minutes yeah
spending two more minutes
check
and now we see the problem this pawn is
saying
and there's no way anymore to defend it
if you play this for example
you will have big problems
move now
king cannot move
the knight
it can move
but look at this
this is residable
to cut things short
check
check this is what he played and this
was the idea i think
of the a4 move
to uh to get this exchange operation in
i think he calculated something like
this
not this
but the capture for example
check
this is a draw for example this is maybe
what job of thought of when he played
the a4 move
that he cannot lose his position which
is true
he will
attack the weakness and black has no way
to
to make any progress in this position
it's just a draw
but carlson didn't do that he just went
back to c7
and yeah this keeps the game going
rajabov is down to two minutes now
and uh well he spent lots of time
with trying to um sort of alter the
position to get a clearer draw
but this always meant you have to
be precise and uh
play sometimes the only moves with real
time on the clock
and this is not easy to do
well okay he took
check oh he didn't take sorry
what he took now
and now we see that you cannot defend
the pawn
check this was the idea getting activity
and uh yeah well
king a6 black's going in extra pawn
and now the question is can
ken white ken white draw this with his
active pieces
he gave the strike king b7 and returned
and here magnus realized that the
planned move knight c6 was not working
due to knight b2
and knight b2 means kramnik is the
challenger
is this what would happen
so not this but
king a6 back repeat it once check
and now he went to
to a7
the point is if white now attacks the
pawn you've got bishop b5 with a
very annoying pin and this is also
um
yeah this is winning for black now
cannot allow this pin
so king d4 is what he played and this is
the issue the king here is very active
in this position
note how important the time management
is
carlson played
played quicker before
and now
he invested
a little bit more than 10 minutes yeah
12 minutes or something to calculate
this
he had he had the time to properly
assess the variations and rajab was down
to one minute
one minute something
and
it's it's also not
only an issue of finding a good move in
a minute
it's also the problem that you're
already playing for six and a half hours
and you're tired it's it's unavoidable
and the combination of all this makes
this really difficult
okay um knight c6 check
what does this should the king do here
i think him
he really should have played king to d5
but it's it's
a hard decision of course
with a little time he played king c5
which is not fatal
king c5
some other software lacked a bit
king d5 is an interesting move and i
think this is what um
what carson calculated so long
just a sample line check
this is the the the complicated thing
and now this move very tricky
knight on the
on the edge of the board
on the corner even and you get g3 and
this is a very tricky position white for
example he cannot play this move it's
very funny
knight g3 and this threatens bishop e8
picking up the bishop and it doesn't
have a square it's quite
it's quite it's a bit of a
tragic piece now he needs to move the
king in a way
and then you
play this and and win with the the pawn
the knight is a notoriously bad piece to
to stop borns
so
after
knight h1 white must play this move
first
it's quite funny this move first
and
you all need to see this in one minute
something
93 and bishop c4 and now the idea is
king f4 attacking and then trying to get
to get rid of the pawns
and i think it should lead to a draw but
my analysis was not uh hours long so
it's uh it's not easy just just a a
sample line
it's silly to go in the corner let's
let's go here
something like this white will get a
couple of pawns back here
and i think um this should
should end in a draw really
black will will get the h pawn
here like this
but white i think has got good good
chances to to draw the position
it's it's possible that we get some sort
of
two minor pieces against one minor piece
end game
so
it's a possible scenario
um and i'm not i'm not 100 sure but i
think it should be a draw
this was
the king d5 move but he went quick went
king here which is not uh it's not
terrible actually
carson played a king here
and now knight c4
why didn't he play king d4 i don't
understand simply
look what puts black suppose so he needs
to return
and then you can go
at least you can go back again
i think he just made a colossal
miscalculation in this in this position
knight c4
probably he was only considering
the capture
and this is indeed a draw we saw
something similar before
with uh this
this bishop move
for example here bishop e8 you can even
go here and draw the game
something like this is just it's just
dead black has no way of winning this
but of course
carson is just giving this check here
and
probably he just overlooked this it's
possible he was down to
a couple of seconds and um
hard to say
yeah here here this is probably gone
if y takes he didn't do that if y takes
black's got
two extra pawns and you cannot capture
of course this is a new queen
and this this should be a win with the
two two pass pawns
it's um
it's not so easy to
analyze this to um to a complete
conclusion
i can just give you a sample line to
illustrate how it how it might work out
something like this
yeah it's a it's a bit of a zucz one the
knight doesn't have many many squares
and it always needs to
um to stay in
or at least return there to take a look
at the pawn
and white will have problems
to um keep the black king out
for example something like this
check
this is important attacking f3 also
a very long line it's just
to illustrate some ideas
for example if now
what should i do if you approach this
now then there's the a pawn coming
check something like
check like this is
you won't survive there's too many
weaknesses
you can also not not take here because
it just promotes
so this this is celestia to the capture
this is why he went here
and um
now very interesting
and a really cool move to make in such a
situation
carlton didn't take on f2 it it probably
wins but
it's um
it's it's not a very controlled way to
to play the position
he played the very nice move knight's
knight to c1
attacking the bishop and it doesn't have
any squares
besides f1 so he went for f1
and now bishop b5 and now you're in a
swan kind of position
very difficult to
to
make any any move here
yeah rajab of um
at the end i decided to
um yeah to take on a5
with the 50 seconds on the clock
um king c3
is the movie he should have tried but
it's probably losing anyway
um
for example let's say
let's say for for example this one
it's rather difficult to
avoid the type of end game that that
that we had before this kind of endgame
it's it's very similar to the one before
and probably lost
but it's it's the one that would have
prolonged the game at least a bit
he took on a5 and they gave away this
bishop because he he hoped that he's got
some counter play with the king and the
the the knight
but council played this very nicely
attacking
the pawn here
and now very precisely
using the king to
to block
white's king from entering
protecting f5 check
and now you're absolutely sure that
there's nothing
bad happening
everything's protected you cannot move
the f-pawn
and let's say
you would go here
simply take this
and black gets a new queen
and this means that this will fall and
the game is totally lost so rajab of
after bishop g4 resigned the game
so i
a titanic struggle of 89 moves
carlson lost in 90 moves against ivan
shook
just to win the next game 89 moves
so um
a big
accomplishment it was not so much
it wasn't a brilliant game or something
by by carlton but it just
was such a great fighting effort to just
grind on and on until the opponent
breaks down
it's um
it's really amazing how often he manages
to to do that where the opponent's down
always posing these little problems
and then with little time on the clock
they
they very often fought them of course
the job off has had a simply
terrible tournament i mean he lost now
it's
it's a fifth or sixth loss on
not sure i think at the sixth sloth
and
it's it's certainly um a factor that
if you play someone whose
self-confidence is shaken
it simply happens if you do so many
games you you simply feel like
feel terrible
um
yeah then i think it's it's um
it's more likely to happen that someone
is breaking down
so now before the last round um
and i will upload this shortly this is
two hours until the last round is
starting
um i really if you have the chance watch
it live it's so so exciting
um okay the last round uh just to
line it out briefly we've got
the two games thousands playing white
against switzerland
and krom nick black against ivan shook
and of course you never know what what
will happen in the rancho crumley game
because eventually can do anything he
can play a brilliant game and win he can
play like
i'm sorry to be direct you play like a
[ __ ] and lose it sometimes really it's
not understandable what it's doing or
you can overstep the time or whatever
anything can happen
um and of course magnus has white
against zwiddler so
i'm
considering the tie break rules it's um
it's it's not difficult anymore to work
it out if carlson wins against sweet
swiddler he wins the tournament and is a
challenger because kramnik at best can
get on the equal amount of points and
then carlton is ahead because he has got
more one games
um in the tie break
if they have the same result
both draw both loose
then um cards and also qualifies
and kramnik only can can do it
if he uh
yeah scores more points
so he needs to
if if card loses for example kramnik
needs a draw
if cards and draws kramnik needs to win
and card has got white against
switzerland certainly will try to play a
sort of controlled game where you can do
a little bit of something but not risk
terribly much
so kramnik basically needs to
try to play for win as like anything
else is curious
it would be quite interesting to see for
example if we run shook place e4 you
never know eventually can do anything
but if he plays e4 what kromnic will
play
he certainly
i cannot imagine him playing the berlin
or something like that he needs to have
some kind of uh
surprise
going
he's not the guy to
um to play something crazy but he needs
to
keep the game going and try to play for
win so it will be it will be very very
uh exciting and also look at carson he
cannot play a draw really you can must
always reckon that event should maybe
overstep the time or something weird is
happening so both players will try to
play for a win
but um
it's certainly very helpful that
carson's got white and the same result
obviously is enough for him he's i think
maybe a 70 percent favorite now or maybe
even more
but um
okay it will be very very exciting
yeah thanks for watching this video and
um
i'll do um of course a wrap-up of the
final round
but um i'm not quite sure when because
it's very much possible that we have two
very very long games that's um it can
happen thanks for watching and uh make
sure to tune in live for the
live broadcast if you've got the chance
thanks